hello I am Sophia Lillis I'm Sophia
Bryant
I'm Richard Ellis and I'm white a lift
we are the cast of I'm not ok with this
and we're going to take a millennial
BuzzFeed quiz called can you pass this
meanwhile at millennial test if I can't
say it probably can't do this which I
guess songs is not by the Backstreet
Boys I wanna oh it's not everybody
bye-bye-bye
I didn't mean to press everybody
I didn't mean to press it which show
starts at angle Laurens Boy Meets World
Saved by the Bell
Daria I'm a big all of these shows
listed here then I just looked at hers I
feel really happy that you I would get
it right thanks and I did very nice boy
meets boy world world what is this phone
called razor and V sidekick or the
blackberry I was wrong I was right I
said we were at Dairy pearl yeah but I
felt like it was too close yeah like I
own a science Pro to kind of look like
that I pretended that like my DS looked
kind of like it that I had to like open
it and the old D s is really big and
bulky like which is not a weight your
character could diet rice to play this
all the time measles snake buy it hit by
a car I don't want to say that I said I
really are getting graded on this like I
remember yeah my car yeah I hit by a car
what kind of lives did these ladies live
over this this sweet sweet life the
secret life the simple life the
hard-knock life do you guys remember
this show yes yeah yeah roll the simple
life I wrote this show was huge
what was the popular social media site
for to thousands kids this time wire
MySpace Club Penguin ass
this one seems aligned even by water a
pirating software yeah that's how you
would get a legal music yeah I knew it
was my space but I pick Club Penguin
that's what - yeah everyone use club
dude we didn't remember MySpace yeah
you're around I remember like older
cousins having it and then be like
remember my mom wouldn't let me have one
yeah yeah she was like people are gonna
stalk you and I was like terrified at
ten years old which group did Beyonce
belong to before she went solo 3lw
cheetah the cheetah girls TLC or
Destiny's Child I was wrong I knew is
just at each other at the kid girl was
this like symphony I got it wrong I'm
the answer there was a movie there was a
movie about the Cheetah Girls and I used
to watch that a lot Destiny's Child I
picked you to girl who is this beautiful
soul Jesse McCartney Ryan Cabrera Harry
Styles Aaron Carter why I just heard her
say it's ominous I don't remember the
song you and your beautiful soul
nothing did you ever even like Barbie
calm yes like Chris Edelen and the best
games yeah but they had like Oh like
their own we actually don't know Paige
and like they would play this song which
of these is not a Spice Girl scary
surprises bordey Spice Posh Spice pepper
spice pepper spice I pick Scary Spice I
was wrong I actually did listen to the
Spice Girls I just didn't know their
names
well not their real I mean like their
spices which of these would you use to
play video games GameCube star box game
box
thank you that's great thank you
I knew this I watched it so anytime at
Thermopylae saying in this scene you're
kidding get out of town shut up you
could watch movies on the iPod Nano
right I downloaded Wizards of Waverly
medical and this movie yeah and I don't
know why I press as it finally which of
these was the quintessential 90s snack
dunkaroos dilly-dally we stick big bug
I'm gonna say dunkaroos sweet sticks
buckaroos nose dunkaroos those are
awesome
well I got a Twitter cats out of the bag
you're just not a millennial that's all
good it just means you can go back and
relive all the greatness of being a 90s
kidz while still being able to use an
iPhone I got 10 12 right so I'm a
millennial Congrats on being a
millennial or at the very least I'm very
in the know Jen's easier it ain't easy
being a member of the coolest generation
but that's just the life we lead it's so
cheap no 12 out of 12 for me same 12 out
of 12 Congrats on being millennial
[Applause]